un pays à l'heure de la guerre
dans les rues de l'hiver la vie semble
normal
mais des signes nous rappellent qu'ici
le deuil est perpétuelle les bouquets de
fleurs n'ont jamais été aussi nombreux
dans toutes les mains de toutes les
couleurs
diana a choisi des roses pour les
funérailles de son ami militaire
avant le 1er avril quand youri est mort
j'étais convaincu que mes amis resterait
sains et saufs confie-t-elle
les funérailles de youri ont lieu en
même temps que celle de notre militaire
d'arras deux soldats morts dans la
région de lougansk dans l'est de
l'ukraine deux pères de famille est acté
c'est celle des
diktats il est maintenant leurs enfants
sont des orphelins 17 femmes comme des
milliers d'autres en ukraine
et les gens font la file ils sont venus
par centaines pour rendre hommage à ceux
qui ont défendu leur pays
dans cette église où sont célébrées les
funérailles de militaires la scène est
devenue presque quotidiennes
sur les visages jeudi la colère le deuil
et la peine
soyons braves ne baissons pas les bras
et vivons dans l'espoir de la victoire
dit le prêtre
des mots pour apaiser la douleur qui
ronge les ukrainiens
diana crois qu'il faut surmonter
l'épreuve accepter ses pairs
sinon c'est l'ennemi qui l'emportent et
nous détruit
[Musique]
avant le dernier adieu un geste
symbolique chacun veut couvrir ces deux
militaires des plus belles fleurs qu'ils
soient
ici louis blouin radio-canada divine